-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-nominated,
Emmy-winning actor you know,
from movies like "Sideways"
and "Cinderella Man,"
as well as the show "Billions."
His podcast,
Paul Giamatti's "Chinwag"
with Stephen Asma,
is available on YouTube
and wherever you listen
to podcasts.
He also stars in
"The Holdovers,"
which is in theaters
now nationwide.
Let's take a look.
-There was an incident
when I was at Harvard
with my roommate.
-And?
-He accused me of copying
from his senior thesis.
Plagiarizing. Ahh.
-Well, did you?
-No!
He stole from me.
But that
blue-blooded prick's family
had allies on the faculty.
I mean, their last name is
on a library, for Christ's sake,
so he accused me in order
to sanitize his treachery,
and they threw me out.
-So you got kicked out
of Harvard for cheating?
-No, I got kicked out
of Harvard for hitting him.
-You hit him?
What, like, punched him out?
-No, I hit him with a car.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
Paul Giamatti, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's so lovely to have you
back here.
-It's a real pleasure
to be back.
Thank you, sir.
-You were scheduled to be here
the first day
of the writer's strike.
You were May 2nd,
which was the first day
we canceled shows.
-And everything shut down.
-Everything shut down.
-Bad luck.
-Ol' Bad Luck Giamatti.
Bad penny.
-Yeah.
-No, it was really --
-Well, I'm glad.
The nice thing is,
we will talk about your podcast,
which we were going to do then,
but we're also,
we have this beautiful movie
to talk about.
I love this so much.
-Thank you.
And this is a movie,
it's called "The Holdovers."
And it's about the kids
who have to stay
at a private school
over the holiday break
because they don't have
anywhere else to go.
-Nobody wants them, yep.
-You're a teacher.
And this was actually
filmed at a school,
the rival school
to where you actually went?
-Which I'd forgotten.
We we filmed in five different
schools to create one school,
and one of them we shot at
was this Deerfield Academy
in Massachusetts,
outside Boston.
And I'd forgotten
it was the rival school
to where I went,
which was Choate.
-Right.
-So when I was there --
I had these kind of
horrible flashbacks
while I was there,
I was like, "Oh, my God,
I remember this place,
going to swim meets,"
which, anybody who was
on a swimming team,
it's the most miserable
sport in the world.
-It's the worst. Yes.
-It's the worst.
And you're in the bus
and it's winter
and it's dark out and
you're leaving and you're wet
and you're chafed
and you're like...
And you've had your ass kicked
in the backstroke event,
and it's just horrible.
-It's horrible!
Also, the way there is even
worse, because it's cold out
and you know,
you're about to get wet.
-That's right,
so it just is all bad.
And that was this vivid,
vivid memory of that.
-This is an interesting,
because it's a period piece,
but it's also a period
you were alive for.
It is the '70s.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for
pointing that out!
-I'm just saying, you played --
-It was weird, because
people kept saying,
"Oh, it's a period film.
I'm like, "That's not possible."
I'm like, period is like,
horse and carriage
and bows and arrows and stuff.
It's not the pipes and
smoking in the movie theater.
I remember that.
-The kid actors are like,
"Ha ha ha. Payphone."
You're like,
"That's not that old!"
-Exactly. [ Laughing ]
In fact, the kid had
a little trouble with the phone.
There's a scene where the kid
gets on the phone
and he was a little like,
"How do I do this?"
And I was like,
"You've got to be kidding me."
-You've got to be kidding me.
Well, he's a wonderful actor.
It's a really great,
really great cast.
And Da'Vine was here yesterday.
-Da'Vine, yes.
-Your wonderful costar.
She was talking
about Alexander Payne,
who directed you in "Sideways."
He does not have a place
for the actors
to go watch themselves
between takes.
He basically just stands
at the camera,
and you don't get to see
your performance
until it's done.
-Which is unusual.
-Do you like it?
-I do. I like it much better.
-Yeah?
-Because it kind of,
it makes it like,
two different workspaces.
It's like, everybody is over
here doing the grunt work,
the actors,
and everybody is over here
having their choco-chinos,
and they're sitting at the thing
and going, "His hair looks
weird, his hair looks funny."
All this kind of [bleep].
It's just like,
it eliminates all that [bleep].
-A good thing to eliminate.
-It's a really good thing
to eliminate.
And then he talks to you.
He's off-camera
and he talks to you,
and it's very relaxed
and intimate-feeling.
-It's a very relaxed and
intimate-feeling movie, as well.
We were talking backstage,
it feels as much like a movie
that was made in the '70s
than that takes place
in the '70s.
-Indeed, and that was the idea,
yeah, yeah.
-There's a really
wonderful scene --
because I remember
the first time
I saw one of my teachers run.
And you play a teacher
and you're running,
you're chasing a student
down the hallway.
And it's so shocking, the first
time you see your teacher,
like, chasing something,
because it reminds you --
you're like,
"Oh, they are human beings."
-They are human beings.
-And they're bad at running.
-Yes.
And this guy's really not...
-How much thought did you
put into the run?
Because it's a really good run.
I didn't have to
think about it very much.
-That's how you run?
-Yeah, you know.
That's kind of how I run.
-Okay, alright.
-I take it all back.
It's a great run.
-The knees are going,
everything.
-You know,
it was a swimmer's run.
I can tell you swam
in your youth.
-Thank you. Thank you very much.
-Your track coach
watched you run once
and was like, "We're going
to get you in the pool, Paul."
-I tried to be a wrestler,
and that did not work at all.
-Well, that actually, you might
have found something worse
than swimming, though.
-Worse, much worse.
Because then
you have to lose the weight.
Wearing the garbage bags
to sweat.
-Spitting in cups.
-Your ears are always
[bleep] up.
-Horrible, horrible, horrible.
-And nobody wants to go.
-No, who cares?
No, nobody wants to go see
swimming, for Christ's sake.
-Swimming is the worst.
Wrestling, at least somebody
might get hurt.
Somebody might, you know --
The worst thing
that's gonna happen,
you're going to whack your
fingers on the edge of the pool
and be like, "Ahh."
-But wrestling, it's bad.
-I think the problem
when I was growing up, like,
because then wrestling
was all of a sudden,
it was like,
world wrestling, right?
And then when you go watch
high school wrestling,
you're like,
"This really stinks."
-Nobody's doing anything!
-There aren't even, like,
ropes to jump off.
-Nothing, and everybody's kind
of still for a really long time,
and nothing's really happening.
-Like, "I feel
like this is holding.
I'm watching holding."
Talking about swimming,
I went and saw Olympic swimming,
so I watched the highest level
of swimming in London.
-Boring.
Now, great on TV,
because again, the only good
vantage point is underwater.
-Oh, that's true.
-Because otherwise, you're just
watching, like, seven splashes.
-You're just watching this,
really slow.
Like this.
-"Oh, I liked that splash."
-And also, the pool,
the atmosphere of a pool sucks.
It's like, it's kind of hot.
It's loud and weird.
It smells like chlorine.
-Yeah, no.
-No, horrible.
-It's like, when you walk
into a baseball stadium,
you're like, "Oh, I love
the smell of fresh-cut grass."
-Yeah, totally.
-But no one's
ever like, "Ah, the pool."
-"Ah, the smell of
the wet bathing suit."
-It is pointed out
by the character in the film,
the kid, that your character
has a lazy eye.
-Yes. I can't remember
what the actual word for it.
-Oh, yeah, I guess it's not.
But my question is,
was this an effect?
Was this a technical?
Are you not allowed to say?
-I'm not at liberty
to discuss it.
I'd have to kill everybody
in here if I talked about it.
-It's a very interesting --
-I'm capable of it.
I'm capable of it.
-Nobody here doubts that.
-I'll try. I'll chase everybody.
It'll be really terrifying.
-This is a weird case
where I feel like
we'd have to give you
a head start.
[ Laughter ]
-That is weird.
It was done in a very --
-It's very subtle and good,
and we weren't sure,
but then we looked,
and so I just --
I want to ask,
there's a contact lens tech.
-Yep.
-I've never seen that
in the credits of a movie.
-Really? Because it happens.
It's not an unusual thing.
-And I'm assuming Zach Ripps
is one of the best.
-Zach Ripps is --
No [bleep], Jack --
Zach Ripps is top drawer.
He's the best at his job.
-If you've got Zach Rips
on your contact lens,
you've got a movie.
-Pop in and out.
-That's how you got a movie.
Well, let me tell you,
we're going to talk about,
we are going to talk about
your podcast when we come back.
But I really,
I can't stress enough,
I think this is
a wonderful holiday film
to watch with family,
and I can't recommend enough.
And we're going to be
right back with more
with Paul after this.